hello isabella and congratulations
thank you so much so i keep hearing
about how collaborative this film was
which is surprising to hear with such a
big movie so is there anything about
maisy that's kind of like purely your
own something that was important to you
you brought it to the table and now we
can see it in the finished film
well i think something that was really
important for me was considering that
maisie is she's still a teenager even
though she is kind of like a clone and
like a
i guess like a piece of science but i
think something that was really
important for me to try and portray was
that she is still a teenager like she's
still growing up and trying to figure
out kind of her place in the world even
though she isn't like 100 human i guess
and i think that that's definitely been
shown in the final product there's a
quality that comes through quite a bit
it's that cool family that adds that
really grounded human element and it
makes uh it contributes to making this
whole world feel real and i love it
so i also love talking about the value
of a good scene partner and you have
quite a few of them with you in this
film so yeah is there anything you saw
one of your jurassic world co-stars do
on set that makes you think you know i
like that i want to put in my back
pocket and take it on to my next film
oh my gosh
so much i mean
even just down to like where to stand in
front of the camera like to make sure
that your face is hit by the light and
stuff and kind of making sure that the
like internalized emotions are you don't
internalize them so you like express
them on your face when you're filming
and stuff
um oh my gosh just i just i feel like
as a general kind of point i learned so
much working on this film because i was
surrounded by such an amazing cast i
think as a die-hard jurassic pen it's
the coolest thing in the world
your first two films your foundation or
jurassic films then you get to take that
specific knowledge to the rest of your
career yeah it's pretty cool
all right so those are your uh human
co-stars but another thing that i really
appreciate about this movie is the
emphasis on practical effects and having
you know some real dinosaurs on set with
use of all the dinosaurs that you got to
work with on set which one would you say
was the best scene partner well i know i
know which one it was um i don't want to
like spoil stuff to give away names and
stuff well we'll run this after the
movie comes out so you're talking oh
okay i think the giganotosaurus was
probably the best one because there was
this giant um head that we had on set
and it felt so real so i think
just like sharing a space with that was
it felt like sharing a space with a
dinosaur to be honest it was it was
pretty it was pretty amazing to work
with yeah like that's my dream come true
and
many people would disagree with that
statement but i hold tight to it
right here here's a question that will
prove that i've learned nothing from all
of these movies so
let's just say you like real you dr wu
approaches you and he tells you he'll
make the dino hybrid of your choice what
two dinos do you combine to make the one
of your dreams oh
that's a that's a really good question
um
i think
well i'm i'm i like velociraptors so
we'll have to throw a velociraptor in
there your first mistake but i love it
and i don't know
oh i feel like
you know what i'll mix it with like a
is you is it diplodocus or diplodocus i
never know how to phrase it yeah i just
feel like that would be a long time to
be able to say and kylo's yours
but i feel like that would be
interesting to see if they mixed those
two so i'd say those two i i feel you
that's a solid choice right there thank
you for your time today and
congratulations thank you for having me